hi herzlich willkommen zum nächsten
video hier auf paris heute habe ich mir
das überlegt das werde ich heute
versuchen die preise von frauen
beziehungsweise mädchen artikeln zu
erraten das heißt so sachen die ich
wahrscheinlich noch nie in meinem leben
gekauft habe weil ich meine teilweise
sind die preislichen unterschiede schon
ziemlich krass mein grab fenster um
klamotten geht habe ich manchmal das
gefühl dass frauenklamotten weil man
sagt ja vor anderen mehr klamotten und
sofort um einiges günstiger sein können
als männer klamotten also vielleicht
habe ich auch falschen eindruck
aber insgesamt wird das glaub ich
relativ interessant heute wir haben zehn
sachen unsere ausgesucht und ich muss
heute erraten wie teuer die sachen sind
ich bin gespannt ob ich es schaffe oder
ob ich komplett untergehen so dann würde
ich sagen so gehen wir mal mit artikeln
numero uno und ich und ich bin gespannt
das ist ich hab ein paar sachen schon
gesehen aber ich habe noch keine
gedanken gemacht also frau assistentin
naked drei von tk zahlt sich hierbei um
schminke oder seht ihr euch selbst in
der kamera übrigens sorry dass das dass
die belichtung nicht so optimal ist aber
wie gesagt hier gibt's halt einfach
keine softbox oder sonst was ja
lidschatten wahrscheinlich oder so und
es sieht schon ziemlich hochwertig aus
die verpackung uk sagt mir auch was es
wahrscheinlich keinen namen marke ich
schätze dabei mal auf 40 eur 53 euro ok
fast für so ein kleines ding 40 euro
leute könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
wahrscheinlich die mädels unter euch
schon aber liebend gerne könnt ihr
übrigens wenn ihr mädels seid könnt ihr
euch nur darüber amüsieren wie ich
versage oder vielleicht manche hatten
richtig mache und die jungs könnten
gerne mal mit raten weil falls ihr euren
freundinnen oder müttern irgendwann mal
so was schenken wollte ein bisschen
teuerstes was hast du als nächstes für
mich nummer zwei gut wenn ich keine
angst
ein schnürsenkel ein schocker leute eine
joker heizkessel die mädels immer so
tragen und so ist das schön
da steht es keine marke dran oder so
bisher immer so das ding also wenn das
von marken ist es halt viel teurer
aber stimmt das eigentlich auch so ein
typisches frauen produkt
ich habe noch wenige männer mit solchen
schockern gesehen also dieser joker hier
relativ simpel würde ich sagen
drei euro verdammt ok schon wieder
versagt von materialien und so ist das
schon relativ einfach aber drei euro ist
aber recht wenig aber ich hab schon
wieder verkauft leute und man da
variieren natürlich die preise also wenn
man das so komplett neu nehmen auf ebay
oder sowas kauft dann kriegt man es
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen günstiger
wieder verpackt nummer drei olala leute
was das ist dürften alle von euch wissen
handelt sich um ein bh ein boot
hersteller soll jetzt am schlusstag ein
bh okay also ich denke mal und wir haben
sieht cool aus ich denke mal da und mbh
kostet denke ich mal 15
meine ich habe bisher zu wenig geraten
20 euro ja genau
genau 20 19 jahre teams zufrieden mit 20
euro
heute an omas nummer vier okay ist
wieder schminke bmw axe wonder stick
kann man es zu sehen
die kamera fox networks wonders deck
düsseldorf als highlight entsteht also
awacs ist glaub so ein dm ding sechs
euro für dieses team 13h controlling
jungs ist wenn man sich konturen ins
gesicht malt durch kontraste hell und
dunkel
ich bin nämlich experten mit ihr wissen
sehr interessant also ich gucke mal
leute sowieso drin ich habe es mal ganz
hoch gedreht es ist echt nicht also für
so ein bisschen farbe ins team natürlich
aus so weit seitiges laserschwert also
schutz frage aber dafür für das bisschen
hier 13 euro also sechs euro wäre da
schon angemessen gewesen also ich finde
eigentlich habe ich trotzdem eins von
vier richtig geraten bzw
ich sag mal als richtig geraten zählt
wenn man in die nähe kommt mehr oder
weniger ok nummer 5 ao k mattierende
tagespflege mit weißem tee ja also
tagespflege spricht dafür dass man es
jeden tag nimmt und sondern wird nicht
zu teuer sein sagt drei euro fünfzig
vier euro das sowas zum beispiel cdl
treffer also 2005 habe ich jetzt richtig
würde ich auch immer sagen okay wir
machen weiter mit numero eins also das
stehe ich nicht falsch aber auch junge
leute das ist so eine extra girlfriend
jeans die genau die ganz locker sind
außer am po das heißt unten ist sie so
weit es gibt auch boyfriend schießt weil
ich mich ich bin einfach experten
überprüfen sie sind komplett weiter aber
ja diese girlfriend jeans marke bershka
also ich denke mal bershka es nicht zu
teuer
ich tippe auf 40 eur 40 euro lag ihr
gutes weiß ein bisschen leichter weil es
natürlich auch für jungs teams gibt ob
jetzt habe ich drei von sechs ich hole
auch weil ich hole auch nummer 7 nähern
uns dem ende ein mascara von patrice
core nenndorf wolle mascara waterproof
also ein ding für die wimpern ich mache
es ja kurzen prozess und sagt 8 euro 50
dieses kann man es verstehen leute das
hier kostet 4 euro und das für zwölf
euro das genau gleich groß und sonstwas
vier euro
also alle 1000 haargummis leute 50h
genießt da ich fragen wo gekauft
primark ich sage fünf euro 15 das was
bei primark los sie könne nichts machen
vorzeitig leute wir machen jetzt machen
mal flott und zwar ist das eine stage of
beverly hills nun scheint glock it und
es glitzert wie verrückt leiter spricht
dafür dass es teuer ist passt gut zu
meinem t-shirt muss ich sagen wieso
sieht das ganze aus
ziemlich cool es handelt sich um ein
glock it also um high life vermutlich
mit eric holder highlighter ich denke
mal dass sie ziemlich teuer aus den
gemeint ist kostet
550 45 euro denke ich okay bin ich
einigermaßen in der nähe
ok dann bin ich jetzt glaube ich bin
glaube ich bereit für die allerletzte
frauensache
es ist ein kylie jenner lippert und so
wie du mir damit in den ort gehört weiß
ich ziemlich genau das ein hit mit
versand und porto in etwa 30 euro kostet
wurde
doch gesagt 34 euro einfach so 29 dollar
in ordnung dort ich würde sagen ich habe
einigermaßen gut abgeschnitten
ihr könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
schreiben jungs ob ihr eine ahnung hatte
top ihr mehr oder weniger richtig
geraten hat ansonsten hoffe ich mal dass
euch das video gefallen hat ich beginnen
den nächsten tagen mit meinen
renovierungen in köln weil wir
vielleicht wisst sich zum 15 ersten um
und ab dann wird sowieso komplett crazy
also da werde ich wahrscheinlich jeden
zweiten tag oder so mit luca ein video
machen und auch ansonsten delhi videos
produzieren ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
und hoffe dass es extrem heiß wird und
ansonsten blass doch gerne mal ein
leichter an schreibt mir jetzt noch dran
seid blau in die kommentare
okay wer macht's gut und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss